hey guys welcome to a GameSpot plays I'm
here with Mary hey and I'm Jake and we
are playing the new Batman Arkham Knight
dlc it's starring Batgirl that's right
we are the Batgirl and this came out
yesterday I believe yep yesterday it is
the first I think it's the it's the
first DLC that's part of the the season
past but this one in particular isn't
actually developed by WB Rocksteady in
fact it's developed by the WB Montreal
the next one will be developed by
Rocksteady though but you finished it
what did you think of it um yeah this is
it's it's alright I I have like ups and
downs with it she's a hacker as you know
so I'm hacking this this thing right now
but sometimes you just need to pull
lever but I wish they would have done a
little bit more with it if the hacking
is pretty easy it's typically as simple
as yeah I don't know just noticing if
your controllers rumbling and then and
then it's as simple as that from what I
saw it was like identical to what was in
Arkham Knight in Arkham City and Arkham
Arkham Asylum it was just kind of like
the you pull out the little play with
the joysticks and try to like make the
word basically wait for it to rumble
right and you don't you know I don't
want to be like too picky about it
because it in many ways I'm actually
really enjoying it I love her moves
she's got some really kick-ass moves and
it's got a lot of what you appreciate
about the the series in this game which
is like the stealth and the sneakiness
and it's really fun to play but I wish
you know I she as a hacker I kind of
wanted her to be a little bit more just
have a little bit more depth in it but
you know overall I've enjoyed it so far
it was a little short for how much I got
out of it yeah one of the problems with
the Harley Quinn DLC is that there
wasn't stuff they took that out
completely and it's nice that this one
you actually use stealth it wouldn't
make sense if you weren't using stealth
Batgirl she's a badass though her moves
are pretty cool yeah and she she's got
selfie moves just like Batman like
you'll see a lot of the same stuff going
on here she's but she's got she's got
her own own stuff going on which I like
about it and she's sneaky and the
stealth moves are really nice in this
which I enjoy and later on you get to
you get to enjoy some stuff with her and
Robin and they can kind of like duel
kick each other's like they kicked butt
together which I really like yeah
similar to like what you could do in
Arkham Knight where someone would you
team up with like Robin or someone and
then you hit
I think that's l1 right go on and then
you do like a dual takedown which those
are pretty nice too like that so what
are you doing right now
well right now I'm dying because I got
stuck in a spot I should have been in
like ideally with these games you want
to be as smoothly as possible
but I got I got I got found out so I'm
kind of hiding out a little bit so I can
be sneaky again and that is that's like
the main thing with this game right you
can do it any way you want which I do
appreciate about these games you don't
have to be sneaky you can you just go
and like do it but I like trying to be
sneaky Oh careful
I think it's cool to do silent takedowns
and she doesn't have the fear attack
like Batman has I'm making noise so
something interesting is that this
considering all the delays and stuff
that happened to Arkham Knight for PC
right this has also been delayed on
passing obviously I actually bought this
on PC and to my dismay I I can't play it
yeah can we play this on console right
now so that's kind of a shame because
like you and some of the other people
who bought the season pass paid $40 for
this season pass you can't actually play
this if they're doing it on concei
because
the game so doesn't quite work yet and
it would have been really cool on PC
like I was stoked to play it on PC it's
just like one more it's one more bummer
thing for PC owners who who wanted to be
able to enjoy this game they just
actually can't you can't yeah you're
you're at a huge disadvantage there's
three of them all together so what's
going on with the ferris wheel there's a
bunch of police on that ferris wheel
right now and they want me to obviously
try and save them but all these guys
have guns so I need to be pretty careful
with how I approach this or they'll
shoot me so I only have so much help so
I'm gonna try and jump around like a
little nimble minx here yes she is fast
she is really fast and that comes in
handy later Oh
that comes in handy later there are
times when no matter how stealthy you
want to be you're actually trapped in a
room with just a bunch of dudes and
you're just stuck with them that kind of
defeats the purpose though it sucks like
I like being selfie I would prefer being
stealthy in every way but I there are
times when they trap her on purpose with
a bunch of dudes so that you're
basically stuck so I should be able to
save these poor men now so let me see if
I can do this it's a very Batman
animations or like take that thing out
now I'm gonna use my little hacker gun
and that should slow this down and now I
move it I'll use a use my vision to see
where the police are there's one there's
a little Skelly
little Skelly Oh No yeah you're scary ya
idiot so he's not doing anything he dead
all right I think I took two huh this
policeman is dad no he woke up yeah he's
fine he had a bit too much to drink
though yeah when I let him swing like
that for a really long time I'd probably
be sick tear yeah I think Ferris wheels
could actually go this fast I feel like
there's probably not a setting on this
fascinating protections in place so that
people can't do it maybe they hacked it
as well I feel like it would just roll
off its hinges right yeah gay crazy guy
there we go this is the same exact same
animation throw up he never bombs he
just like I think it's internal I can he
swallowed it okay he's a professional
you know that was it there's only two
men there that's it all that work for -
I know so the audio like we're mean
sorry if some of the story and like the
writing is as you would expect from a
game like this which is like there's a
bomb yeah
and you got to go defuse the bomb and
but there's nothing wrong with it you
got to accept that I think about these
games and I think if you embrace it you
might find that you you like it yeah oh
I mean that's the one thing that kind of
stood out is right when you start it's
like oh that girl needs to save someone
but Batman can't come and Robin's here
too and it's just kind of like okay
let's go with this that makes sense I
guess so is that a giant metal shark did
you just hit that I noticed like when I
finished it you're just in the same area
and the map does not show the city it
doesn't it only shows this area so my
guess is No yeah but I don't know how
much it would actually stop you yeah I
think I think it does for that yeah
because I know I think with Arkham City
they had Catwoman DLC and that was just
like missions that took place in the
world and so far I know what the Harley
Quinn DLC in this DLC you don't actually
get to explore the world as these
characters you're kind of confined to
smaller areas yeah they kind of keep you
on this little area where you're come on
I gotta hurry up and take these guys
down because we're wasting time we're at
46 seconds there's like a little it's
like a little oil rig right with a all
right moment of truth
oh my god I'm not doing this charm
yeah yeah so I was right sure all the
time
I remember charlatan how dare he all
right
so in this one yeah Robins a I was like
pretty interesting like he basically
just she's just looking at you yeah
he follows what I do he's taking a break
yeah he hangs out all right so this part
isn't timed at least so this is like the
last objective in this area right yeah
there's a lot more to do actually this
was longer than I thought it would be
there was like a whole part where I
don't you get too spoilery you know like
there's Gordon and I gotta like get
Gordon and save some people this part
sucks this is like the party I don't
enjoy and it's because the whole point
about that girl I really well Batman in
general is that you get to be sweetie
you get to choose how you want to beat
things you could be more secretive where
and get things from above and in this
particular part I can't get out and
dudes drop in oh yeah this is exactly as
you described and I appreciate going
stuck in here like 30 people and now I I
just kind of have to be be really quick
and my tactic is because she's she's
actually really she's really seedy so
Robins I can help you know it's just me
and the dudes keep coming in as well
like they will just keep coming and I
have to be really fast and I just
basically have to like jump around back
and forth and move around as fast as I
can
she she's very speedy just like Batman
she's got a lot of his signature moves
but I think she's a little quicker and
she feels quicker but look how many
people there are in this tiny space with
me if I get hit like just like a three
or four times I'm in trouble so I have
to like just constantly
around this area I got hit with about so
I'm just jumping around the room because
there's less chance that they'll kill me
yeah I just I just keep moving quick
did you hear that wood are you Batman
secretary there's a badass secretary
yeah place your [ __ ] up secretary so
this takes place before Arkham night
right I guess I have to I mean I'm sorry
alright yeah that's fine we're almost
there I really know again cuz it's um
it's not a fun area
today's area I think I did it I think
you did it I did it okay good course
they're drowning
oh no they will not they will know if
they die maybe not geralyn's all for
nothing I'm not doing it again stop
choosing things I don't want I need to
get them out before they drown it's
really bad girl she's she's on it
she knows the score alright good
of course see you got to make that in a
bad shape of course that's the standard
way yay so that's like a that's like a
weird part right because you're stuck in
here and you can't get out but right now
I can immediately get out so it's just
video games this is part one of this
Batgirl one right there supposed to be
another one did I hear that right
or not yeah I've heard there's but she's
a returning character look unlike Harley
who's like that was like a one-time
thing
and that's fine with me because I didn't
find her to be as fun as this character
yeah like she she seems to be way more
fun to play like I enjoy playing as
Batgirl yeah you know like the hacking
mechanic it's like all right whatever
but I enjoy playing as her I know so say
you're still on the fence whether or not
you want to buy this season pass do you
think this is a good thing to push you
over to buy that season pass to get this
early along with all the other content
or would you wait maybe see if there's
something better that comes in the
future right I mean so far it's hard to
say whether or not like it is not
validated by this that girl itself
doesn't validate it so I couldn't say if
it's worth it or not because it depends
on what else comes around yeah and if
it's nothing good then no it's not would
it be worth it because this is itself it
was fun but it's not worth the price
that I'm saying and unless something
else is really good so then say like we
get something like this say every every
other week or every month for the next
six months would it be worth it banner
do you still think it feels kind of
mediocre in that case yeah this one
didn't feel it's pretty short I think
what you can beat it in an hour it's not
you know it's not awful it's just that
you know when you're putting into that
kind of money you really I think have to
give them their money's worth and you
just won't know until later but this is
not a bad start I think there's some
sloppy pieces to it I'd like to see what
the other yeah you know what the next
one holds because as you said this isn't
team Rocksteady like this isn't what we
come to expect it's not awful it's just
I would like to see something else so
you can say if you're really itching for
more Batman Arkham Knight then this
would probably be worth it if you're if
you got your fill with Arkham Knight
maybe not this isn't quite enough to
pull you back in no not for me
I do a dual team yeah all right yeah
yeah Boy Wonder there's another electric
grid over there
Oh about I think she's gonna kill that
guy I'm just standing over him just hit
him right in the [ __ ] let's go to the
top of the tower didn't you'll actually
be able to do something as Robin and for
a future deal see yeah I bet
probably like I'd like to play as Robin
he seems like a rad dude yeah
Robin plays Nightwing I'd like to play
more as villains though too
there's a lot of strong villains in this
game for sure they just don't get um
they don't get as many cool items as
Batman does you know yeah well anyway
that was Batman Arkham Knight DLC this
was the a family matter yep a matter of
family family family I think family I
don't know it's basically the arkham
knight dlc it is out now for season pass
holders for PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
unfortunately you can't get this on PC
yet yet they're working on fixing the PC
version before they get any DLC out so
unfortunate if you bought the season
pass you're not getting things early you
yeah so I wouldn't recommend buying it
because there's no value to it right now
so you could just buy the pieces as they
come out when they actually come out for
peace yeah
the only way that you would actually get
value for your money for that's been and
you kind of pick and choose which ones
you want right I'm Jake this is Mary and
it's been a game spot plays bye